>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Akile Gursoy,
thank you for agreeing
to be with us today.
I know that you are an accomplished
chairman of the department
of anthropology at the
university here in Turkey.
That you have written,
that you have researched,
that you're working
on issues of women.
And you gave an absolutely wonderful
keynote speech at the conference,
the [inaudible] conference
here in Istanbul.
And the Library of Congress who's
filming this whole thing was wanting
very much to have you
to highlight the profile
of such an accomplished
woman as yourself.
I would very much like to know
something about your background.
How did you become
who you are today?
And so do give us an idea.
Where you were you born?
>> Akile Gursoy: Thank you very
much for all your compliments.
You put me in a sort
of central big light.
For myself, I was born in Ankara,
at the capital city of Turkey.
My parents and their
families come from the Balkans
and from Central Anatolia.
And I was educated
initially in Ankara.
Coming from the a political family,
we had a lot of some
upheavals in our life course.
So I continued my high
school education in Istanbul,
and later I went to England
to Cheltenham Ladies' College
to pick up my A levels there.
I went to university in English
to Durham University
to study anthropology.
But after I finished, all the rest
of my life I came back to Turkey,
and I have been working
in my home country.
Teaching at the university.
For a couple of years, I worked in
Eastern Turkey in a health project
in trying to reduce child mortality.
That was some, for me it was
a significant part of my life.
I have, I am presently
trying to build a department
in a newly founded
university in Istanbul.
So this is.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Is
it a private university?
>> Akile Gursoy: It is
a foundation university.
It is not exactly private maybe in
the sense of being totally private.
But in Turkey we have a history
and a traditional foundations.
And this is a modern foundation.
So it is, in one sense
it is very closely linked
to this central state
university system,
but at the same time it has an
independent private functioning
nature to it.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: How did
your family influence you?
You said you came from
a political family.
And tell me a little
bit about your family.
>> Akile Gursoy: I, yes.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: I heard, I
heard some rumors, but tell me,
your grandfather plays a
very important role in.
>> Akile Gursoy: Well,
my grandfather was,
he was the last prime
minister of [inaudible].
He was with him in his last years.
They were very good friends.
And later the way history
developed, he was the president
of Turkey between 1950 and 1960.
So that is my one generation
political background.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb:
Legacy, that's right.
>> Akile Gursoy: Legacy.
And my mother, she was also
a member of parliament.
Due to political circumstances
later in her life, she had decided
that it would be a good
idea to end her politics.
So she was involved in politics,
she was a member of parliament
for I think almost ten years.
But for myself, I am much
committed to academic life,
to wanting to work
with young people.
This comes as a priority in me.
I do not have much interest
in daily actual politics.
Politics, politics.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: So
you had wonderful mother,
but you created your own
niche, your own way of life.
>> Akile Gursoy: I think so.
I was.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: You
chose your own way.
>> Akile Gursoy: Yes, yes.
But in my family, I can say
that from my childhood onwards,
I think this is something
that holds for many children,
many women for our
part of the world.
My family was very much
interested in my education.
My father, my grandfather,
and my mother.
They had high expectancy
of how we would perform.
Not just myself, but my sisters.
They were very interested in our
grades and how we did at school.
So I think we got a lot of
backing from them morally.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb:
Support is very important.
>> Akile Gursoy: Support is very
important for women, I think.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: But what got
you interested in anthropology?
>> Akile Gursoy: Yes, people
are always asking this
because it's not a very usual.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Usual, no.
>> Akile Gursoy: Usual subject area.
I think had I never gone out
of my own country to study,
maybe I would not at all
have realized that there is
such a discipline as anthropology.
But I think moving away from
home at a very young age
and entering a boarding
school in England,
it suddenly made me realize
how there can be very
different lifestyles.
How people can think differently,
live their daily courses
very differently.
So this lead me to think
about different customs,
different societies.
And in my final year at
Cheltenham Ladies' College,
we were receiving a lot of
advice, advisory from the teachers.
And when we talked about
these interested, you know,
I said I'm really interested
how food can be different,
beliefs can be different,
lifestyles, everything, music.
So she started giving me books on
anthropology, and the more I read,
the more I became interested
in how throughout the whole
world all these different
lifestyles coexist.
I ended up studying anthropology.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: And you focused
on Turkey in your PhD dissertation.
>> Akile Gursoy: Yes.
My PhD dissertation was so
when I came back to Turkey.
Of course, then I started
family of my own.
I was married, I have a son.
And much as I would have liked to,
I did not go abroad to do research.
I did all my research
work here in Turkey
which is a very large country.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb:
Absolutely, absolutely.
And a very rich one, too.
>> Akile Gursoy: A very rich one.
So my.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb:
And what was your.
>> Akile Gursoy: PhD, yes.
My PhD dissertation topic was on
women workers in a tea backing
and brewery factory in Ankara.
I looked at their relationship
with the syndicates
and how their adaptation
to city life
and how they managed their
lives working as workers
in this tea packing factory.
So my PhD research topic was in a
way on the anthropology of labor,
on urbanization, on women's issues.
But as soon as I completed my
PhD topic before I had time
to even develop it further,
I had this offer from UNICEF.
They asked me if I
would be interested
in being their communications
officer
for this program they were starting.
And the program had one foot at
the Turkish Ministry of Health.
This was in the 1980s.
The other part was
Southeastern part of Turkey.
So I quit academic life.
I thought I would never
come back to academia,
that I would spend the rest of
my life doing development work
and working in villages in small
towns around health issues.
So I joined them for two years,
and that was a very
enriching experience for me.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb:
Actually, that's wonderful
because I had exactly
the same experience.
I joined UNICEF as well
and worked with women
and children in villages
for a while.
But then you came back
after a while, that's it.
>> Akile Gursoy: I was
maybe a little frustrated
or maybe a little too idealistic.
I felt I was not able to do as much
as I felt I should be doing
given the circumstances.
So I moved myself out from UNICEF
and started looking for a job.
And among, there was a period
of time I was searching
for a job, something to do.
And my son was very
young at the time,
so it was not very easy
committing myself to jobs
that would require a lot of
travel, a lot of other commitments.
And eventually I entered a
very large state university
in Istanbul, Marmara University.
I worked there for about 15 years.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: In the
anthropology department?
>> Akile Gursoy: They had
no anthropology department.
I worked, it was, again,
a university that was
big in formation.
Throughout my life, I seem
to have entered places
where they are in a
stage of formation.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: But that's always
exciting because you [inaudible].
>> Akile Gursoy: That's true.
You kind of help the
structure being formed.
I found myself eventually
at the Department
of International Relations,
so I have also studied a lot
of their theories and I'm familiar
about the international
relations' outlook to life as well.
But when I was there in my
last years, we were trying
to form a social science department
with my colleagues, sociologists,
anthropologists, psychologists.
And as we were trying to achieve
this in a state university,
the way things developed, I had
an offer from Yeditepe University
to come and develop the
anthropology department
which became a very
exciting offer for me,
and I changed my life course.
And that is what I have been doing.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: And you, in
a way, established it, isn't it?
I mean, the anthropology department?
Or you expanded it.
>> Akile Gursoy: I
established it, I guess.
And I would like to expand it more.
We have some very interesting
courses being taught.
We have very, I believe,
very good students.
One of them is presently right now
in Mongolia studying Shamanism.
We have very interesting projects.
I'm very happy to be there,
and I hope for some years
to come I will stay and continue
to develop the department.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: And it
is important, you know,
to work on the culture
and the society.
And as you said, you know,
those very first ideas
that got you excited in
anthropology, sort of all the ones
that you're following
through now with your work
in anthropology, isn't it?
>> Akile Gursoy: Yes, in that sense
I think I am lucky I am doing things
that are still relevant to my
own significances in my mind.
Of course, there's also a lot
of administrative work
I do, but [laughs].
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: We all
have to do some of it.
>> Akile Gursoy: To do some of
the things that maybe we would
like to diminish time wise, yes.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb:
But in your students,
you find the same excitement
about anthropology,
about studying the culture
in the students you have
in the anthropology department?
>> Akile Gursoy: I think I do.
I think despite the fact
that now there is a kind
of generational difference, I think.
I see this maybe in my son, in
all the young people I meet.
They have a different way
of relating to issues,
to how they will spend their time.
They are maybe much more
realistic about certain things.
But they are, I think,
committed, and they are ready
to give a lot from themselves.
They work hard, so I'm
very happy with them.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: That's great.
Well, thank you so much, Akile.
And thank you for sharing these
wonderful experiences with us.
And I know that many will
follow in your footsteps,
and I'm sure you're
going to be inspiring,
and you are inspiring your
students and many beyond that,
beyond Turkey and outside.
>> Akile Gursoy: Thank you.
You are very kind.
I will look forward to listening
to all of the other interviews.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: You have
made a major contribution
to it, to our program.
Not only with your
presentation yesterday but also
with sharing your personal
ideas and hopes and wishes.
>> Akile Gursoy: Thank
you very much.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Thank
you so much, Akile.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.